our democracy types
are actually not only disdainful of
their fellow countrymen
they're actually willing to attack basic
elements of our actual constitutional
democracy there was an la times
columnist
virginia heffernan who just
made a pretty radical suggestion about
people who exercise their second
amendment rights very basic civil rights
in this country
she said real estate listings should
include the prevalence of gun ownership
in a 50-mile radius
and a number of annual mass shootings in
the region time to change what a bad
neighborhood
is and introduce a meaningful tax on
guns and gun violence no one should say
this is a great place to raise kids
about neighborhoods where even one
person has an assault rifle
we don't need to rehash the obvious
points that what she thinks an assault
rifle is it's not actually an assault
rifle and
yada yada you get it i want to focus on
the call here she's asking
that the addresses of gun owners be
published
making them targets making them targets
for burglary making them targets for
ostracism making them targets for
violence for for exercising a very basic
right
the journal news actually where i where
i grew up in new york did this some some
years ago
they published lists of of the addresses
where
gun owners live the places that these
gun owners are
i don't even just want to focus on that
i want to focus on the divergence
between
what she's suggesting in reality she's
saying we need to redefine what a bad
neighborhood is and now we're going to
we're going to define a bad neighborhood
as places where people have
ar-15s
the problem with that is those aren't
bad neighborhoods
people have ar-15s in good neighborhoods
ar-15s are just not used in very many
crimes
very very few this is a well trodden out
statistic it's almost become tedious
more people are killed each year with
bats and hammers and clubs and fists
than they are with rifles of any kind
including the dred ar15 now guns are
involved in some crimes
much more often pistols that's much more
often not
not in the trump counties okay it's more
often in chicago in detroit
and washington d.c and new york and los
angeles not places that are voting for
donald trump not places
that are great defenders of their second
amendment rights not places that are
buying the ar-15s
actually this woman has undermined her
own argument here because she's saying
that all these places you know out in
the country where people have ar-15s
those are the bad neighborhoods they're
not we know they're not
you know they're nice neighborhoods
actually people like to go there they
have high real estate prices okay
and they're not even you know they're
someplace you know if you go to a city
for instance there will be high real
estate
prices depending on what neighborhood
you're in but there's so much economic
opportunity and you're making a lot of
money
and there's lots of social services and
high taxes and all but we're talking
about places that are just sort of nice
you know that people actually would like
to go to
it's an after you can't just redefine
reality that way the left loves
redefining reality that's
sort of the central premise of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available you can get a signed first
edition copy
at premiere collectibles books coming
out in two weeks at which point i will
not be able to say it's available for
pre-order it will just be available for
order
hey there if you don't ring that bell
and subscribe to this channel you
are a threat to our democracy you are
you are undermining
our democracy if you don't get these
notifications also head on over to apple
podcasts
google play spotify stitcher gmail i
don't know are we on
wherever you got your audio podcast head
on over subscribe to the michael notre
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time